in the striking setting of the eden
project there was
only one star the queen and expert
in these photo opportunities on
sparkling form
how's that are you supposed to be
looking as if you're enjoying
for the leaders this was clearly a
moment not to forget
all of them jockeying to have their time
with a head of state
without equal
it was a real coup for the prime
minister not just the monarch but her
family
traveling to cornwall to support him the
ultimate display
of royal diplomatic charm
number 10 know that a meeting with the
queen will literally
mean the world to some of these leaders
yes the impact is subtle and that's why
it's described as
soft power but so often over the years
it has made a huge difference
in securing those foundations of
friendship when difficult discussions
lie ahead but for the prince of wales
this was an evening of opportunity when
it comes to the climate crisis
in a first for a g7 summit 10 global
ceos who joined him
and prince william to meet the leaders
and discuss how governments
and business can work hand in hand
the prince even using one of the prime
minister's slogans
to put his point across to build back
better
we need above all a truly effective
partnership
between government and business
the fight against this terrible pandemic
provides if ever one was needed
a crystal clear example of a scale
and sheer speed at which the global
community can tackle
crises when we combine political will
with business ingenuity and public
mobilization
fashion designer stella mccartney is
supporting the prince
and believes that only with changes in
laws and regulation
can her industry become more green
i think to represent the fashion stream
one of the most harmful industries the
environment
in this kind of room is a huge honor
and i'm just really excited to just talk
about the problems that we face as an
industry
and try to present some of the solutions
the queen camilla and kate squeezed in
another engagement
thanking volunteers who've worked so
hard during the pandemic
yes they can certainly work a room but
this wasn't just about sending the
leaders home happy
but making a genuine difference on some
of the most pressing global issues
of our time there is a knife i know
there is
the anon mills sky news instant austal